by now I'm sure you've all heard about
the supply shortage it's all over the
news and many of you have likely
experienced it firsthand I mean it's no
secret that wait times and prices for
many everyday items have gone through
the roof to make things worse it looks
like things are only getting worse take
Tesla for example wait times for the
model 3 are three to six months wait
times for the model y are six to nine
months wait times for the model S are
three to six months wait times for the
model X are 9 to 12 ones and the Cyber
truck is nowhere to be found clearly it
Tesla has months of backlog for all of
their vehicles yet their Q2 production
numbers are down nearly 50 000 in
comparison to q1 and this is despite
opening two new gigafactories within the
past couple of months according to Elon
these factories are currently gigantic
money furnaces because they simply can't
get enough parts to reach a scale that
they need to it's not just Tesla that's
facing these issues either even apple is
worried as a blockchain constraints will
affect their top line by several billion
dollars but why is this still even an
issue our freight networks Trucking
networks Airline networks and
communication networks are all more
advanced than ever so you would think
that such an issue would be solved
within a matter of months but we're two
years into this problem and things are
only getting worse so what's up with the
supply shortage
starting with the most obvious reason we
have the pandemic while much of the
world has returned to normal life the
effects of that pandemic are still quite
evident throughout the supply chain
first of all China is still regularly
implementing lockdowns and even some of
their biggest areas like Shanghai and
given that a significant portion of our
everyday items are produced in China
it's not surprising that these lockdowns
are taking a toll on the global
Marketplace it's not just lockdowns that
we have to worry about either kovid has
brought with it a slew of new safety
protocols from regular testing District
quarantine measures and this I simply
add more friction when it comes to
maximizing production and Logistics but
even if lockdowns and coveted protocols
were left behind you would face issues
regarding labor shortages you see it
when the pandemic hit many companies
scaled back production to prepare for
potentially weak demand this meant
shutting down factories and laying off a
significant number of employees this
made sense at the time but demand has
recovered faster than anyone expected
not to mention it in some Industries it
demand is higher than ever because
people have been excited to return to
normal life the problem however is that
it takes time to scale production while
you can shut down a factory overnight
you can't just turn it back on overnight
a great example of this is Tesla
gigafactories It generally takes years
for these behemoths to reach their
strides and even then they still have
years worth of optimization left also
it's not just one or two factories that
were shut down much of the supply chain
as a whole will shut down so everyone is
having to scale back up all over again
to make things worse it's been extremely
difficult to find enough labor to run
these factories and Logistics networks
this was already an issue before the
pandemic started but the pandemic has
just made a problem substantially worse
instead they found a new job that were
more flexible and paid better by now I'm
sure you've all heard about the great
resignation and one of the hardest hit
Industries is manufacturing right now
the US is short 3.5 million
manufacturing workers and the worst part
is that 2 million these positions that
aren't expected to be filled this is
definitely not a good sign for supply
chain issues easing it anytime soon and
the given that 82 of manufacturing
Executives feel that labor shortages are
one of the key reasons that they're
struggling to meet demand and increase
productivity this Supply shortage could
easily last for years to come it's not
just manufacturing workers that are
missing either we're seeing shortages
and Logistics side of things as well the
American Trucking associations estimates
that the driver's shortage has increased
from roughly 60 000 before the pandemic
to 80 000 today so not only has the
pandemic reduced number of people who
are producing Goods but also the number
of people who are delivering Goods
foreign
major labor and scaling Miss Supply
chains have also been challenged by
inflation the price of raw materials
have skyrocketed throughout the pandemic
and while they have cooled down from
their peaks there is still a ways to go
take aluminum for example before the
pandemic started it aluminum cost
roughly 1700 per ton at the start of the
pandemic prices briefly cooled down to
1500 before they exploded to nearly four
thousand dollars in February of 2022.
since then prices have come back down to
2 400 but that's still 40 higher than
where they started a similar story can
be seen with Lumber before the pandemic
Lumber generally cost 300 to 400 per
1000 board feet from there Lumber
crashed 250 dollars before rocketing to
an eye watering 1600 fortunately we've
cooled back down to a little over 600
but that's still over 60 higher than
where we started this price volatility
has made everyone within the supply
chain extremely cautious because they
don't want their business to become
unprofitable for example let's say you
own the company that produces chassis
for iPhones you already committed to
making X number of chassis at a given
price but since you made this commitment
the price of aluminum has doubled which
leaves your business unprofitable at
this point you have two options you can
either go to Apple and renegotiate a
higher price which will likely take
weeks if not months or you can wait for
aluminum prices to cool down before you
ramp up production which will also take
weeks if not months meanwhile if you're
about to form a new manufacturing
contract with let's say Samsung you're
probably going to quote them a higher
price to protect yourself from Price
fluctuations and when Samsung hears this
high price they're going to be inclined
to get more quotes before they lock in a
manufacturing contract and all of this
just slows down the process of meeting
demand also keep in mind that most of
these companies that aren't just dealing
with one supplier Apple for example has
over 200 suppliers so Apple would have
to troubleshoot the same issue over 200
times at the same time I don't think I
need to explain how this could quickly
turns into a supply chain nightmare to
make things worse ample's issues won't
be solved once they get all the
suppliers on board now they have to
worry about actually transferring the
finished product to the customer
fortunately gas prices aren't that bad
wait never mind crude oil is floating at
over 100 per barrel I don't even think I
need to explain why this is a problem
because most of you have likely dealt
with obscene gas prices first hand now
companies could just go ahead and raise
prices like many of them have been doing
but with recession fears being rampant
consumers are more price sensitive than
ever last quarter Netflix lost nearly a
million subscribers so there's no doubt
that consumers are cutting back on
expenses so the last thing companies
want to do is raise prices too fast and
lose even more customers as a result
many companies have decided that it's
better to have customers way to acid try
to Source cheaper materials than it is
to have customers leave it because they
raised prices and this mindset is by no
means helping the situation
foreign
along with inflation were already
massive challenges to deal with but now
we also have to deal with the Russia
Ukraine war neither Russia nor Ukraine
are massive manufacturing players per se
but this isn't to say that they don't
have a significant impact on the global
supply chain Ukraine was one of the
world's top sources for neon now neon
may seem irrelevant but it's actually
extremely relevant when you consider
that neon plays a crucial role in
tamagon Archer manufacturing you see it
neon is required to run the lasers that
are used in the chipmaking process and
given that 90 of the neon that was used
to produce U.S ships came from Ukraine
this is not a great sign neon wasn't the
only item that came from Ukraine either
the war has also cut off significant
supply of nickel aluminum weed and
sunflower oil and all of that is just
Ukraine's side of things Russia is the
third largest oil producer and the
second largest oil exporter cutting off
Russian oil is one of the main reasons
that gas prices have gone insane over
the past few months and given that these
sanctions likely won't be easing anytime
soon Transportation networks are gonna
have to get used to higher fuel prices
aside from oil Russia is also the
world's second largest natural gas
producer and the world's largest natural
gas exporter given that the
manufacturing industry is heavily
dependent on natural gas the supply
chain is going to have to get used to
higher natural gas prices as well aside
from raw materials the war has also
disrupted major transportation networks
here's the thing Russia is literally the
biggest country in the world by far so
when you cut off all cargo trains planes
and ships from this region it becomes a
lot harder to transport Goods in China
for example over a million containers
became stuck in the logistics Channel
when the war started these containers
were supposed to be transported to
Europe by a train that travels through
Russia but now all of them have to be
transported by sea so the Russia Ukraine
war is not only taking a massive toll on
raw materials but also an international
Transportation Networks
foreign
[Music]
best the global supply chain is like a
gigantic spider web that has been
created through Decades of producing it
scaling it and delivering and out of
nowhere three giant baseballs have been
thrown at this spiderweb the first
baseball is the pandemic the lockdowns
layoffs and Factory shutdowns brought on
by covid-19 have been catastrophic
scaling up production back to full
capacity is a time consuming Endeavor
and this has been especially challenging
due to labor shortages the second
baseball is inflation the price
increases in raw materials labor and
fuel have led to higher expenses and
every step of the supply chain meanwhile
companies are trying to minimize price
hikes to maximize customer retention and
this has simply let the companies
putting supply chain issues on the back
burner instead of addressing them
head-on and finally the third baseball
is the Russia Ukraine war not only has
the war cut out several Key Resources
such as neon natural gas and oil but it
has blocked off almost all cargo
Transportation through Russia the these
three baseballs have left three massive
holes within a supply chain spiderweb
and this is not something that can be
fixed overnight given that millions of
manufacturing jobs will remain vacant
the clear solution is to lean towards
automation which will take years to
develop similarly it took over a year
for inflation to ramp up to where we are
right now and even if this is the peak
you'll likely take another year for
inflation to cool back down and as for
the Russell situation even if the war
ended today it'll take years if not over
a decade to repair relations so our best
bet is to Simply find new sources for
natural gas oil and a neon but this will
again take time so you should probably
Buckle in because this crazy ride is far
from being over but that's just what I
think when do you think supply chain
issues will ease comment that down below
also drop a like if you hope supply
chain issues is sooner rather than later
and of course consider checking out our
Discord Community such as future video
ideas and consider subscribe and see
more questions that logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one
[Music]